so I don't do
but I do collect things
and I love collecting like
little vintage containers and also a lot of Sterling silver
so in that I have a lot of fun little containers that if I did do
that I would put it in
I just wanted to show you
so first of all
I have this this is um
like the first thing that I got that I was like
oh this is
if I did that
I would do that
I use it for perfume
um so this is like a poison uh
a poison ring
and I got this in New Orleans um
there's like a Hurricane in Florida
and we had to drive
and currently I just keep like
this is really old
um I haven't used this in a while
but I currently keep um
like a little cotton pad with some oil
so like
when I move around
like fragrance oil and it's like perfume
but if I did this would be a great place to put it
okay also
I recently got this
and this is a Sterling silver needle holder
like for sewing needles
I when I bought this
thought this was much bigger
because I thought that it would be good to hold a cigarette uh
but it much smaller than I anticipated
it has like
a little thing
so tell me that would be like
a cute little necklace
and if I did this would be
you know this would be really perfect
um I just cleaned it
all of this came off this little thing anyways
so there's this
then I have a couple of these
Estee Lauder vintage
like um
solid perfume holders um
and so they have like these little
like little amber um
like perfumes and they're awesome
um I would put a little
little baggy in here personally
like I just like it would be so cun ty
and there's this um
Estee Lauder has like a bunch of these
I also have a pendant one
here's the pendant
it's just the same concept
like a little amber perfume solid perfume
also I have this like
little pearl cage which I could definitely put my antidepressants
and I think that would be cute
wellbutrin
and I also have this
I don't know if you can see it
this like comes out and then this opens up
I'm sorry literally what other purpose would I have for this
empty space what else am I putting in here literally
what is the point of this
you know what the point of this is
ah what
so tell me what I should be putting in here
cause I'm obviously—
I have enough issues
I don't do that
like I think I would go like
I have ADHD also
so like I just
you know like
my medication is literally meth(amphetamine, aka adderal) right
so like I don't think I need to be adding anything else to the mix
you know um
so
but like if you guys have any ideas for like
what I can hide in these
like little like
like you're joking
like what else
this be for I don't know
I like little trinkets
and for some reason
a lot of little trinkets just have secret like
places to store things
I'm only a person
what am I supposed to what
what conclusion am I supposed to come to anyways
this is the consequence of hyperfixating on buying Sterling silver on eBay
and I'm not gonna stop
I am addicted
I also have this
is it um
800 silvers is like vintage and a vintage silver compact
it's 800 silvers is not Sterling silver
and this comes out
so I just like
put it in here and like
you know just like
handle it and the most of this would be like
this would be my like
go to ha ha
it's this little perfume container and I'm gonna use
I have a perfume oil again
that I use I always basically smell like rose and baby powder cause I have this
like one um
like rose oil
and it's again
this is for perfume
but like is it for perfume
is that what it was intended for
I don't know that's what I'm gonna use it for because
that's what I'm gonna use it for
and I'm gonna have it hanging on
like a little necklace
but like if
tell me this wouldn't be like
the perfect use anyways
I just like
I spend a lot of time on eBay
and I spend a lot of time like
looking at vintage sterling silver stuff
and they just like
they made a lot of stuff
for sn uff and like
they're so cool
but I just like
I have no use for that
so I just like
I'm like what am I gonna make these like
little tiny containers for
anyways that's my show and tell